but then you hear the troops hey we're
going to pull the troops from
afghanistan the withdrawal you remember
this when it was in april they were
talking about it
and both hillary clinton and condoleezza
rice on opposing ends neither one of
them supported it they said that's not a
good move to make
and we should stay there because if we
pull out things could get pretty ugly
you know it could be
you know more war more you know
others could take over and we're going
to empower those guys
somebody may say well david i i'm all
for your noble causes
but if we pull troops out of all these
different places
and say everybody has to solve their own
problems themselves and a full-on war
breaks out proxy wars manipulative wars
does that affect us at all
and if it doesn't
okay in what ways do you think it
doesn't affect us but if it does should
we just stay there
so first of all i i think you know
hillary clinton and condoleezza rice
should have very little credibility when
it comes to speaking on matters of
foreign policy these are the architects
of the last 20 years of war these are
some of the architects of the
wars in afghanistan and iraq and for
example libya which is uh turned into a
terrible proxy war and uh
uh you know a dissolved state
effectively in in libya that where
hillary clinton was the
the leading light in in launching that
war um
the the fact is we are in a state of of
warfare
in many parts of the globe uh wars that
often the united states military has
launched or gotten deeply involved in uh
as well as proxy wars uh and continuing
with the status quo is just going to
continue
these wars the united states needs to
shift its emphasis from warfare to
diplomacy to trying to end these wars
diplomatically
you know
yes
afghanistan looks terrible right now
but the solution was not to just keep
the united states military in
afghanistan in perpetuity uh which is
essentially what we've been well what
u.s leaders have been doing for the last
20 years another path needs to be
pursued and i'm glad that by the
administration announced the withdrawal
of most not all u.s troops from
afghanistan
but it needs to go much farther to try
to reduce uh and minimize the violence
and damage that is going on there as
well as in the other war zones where the
united states should rapidly remove
itself so if you like this sort of short
club from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you